[Music]
foreign
and his dad my grandpa got me really
into movies and I just that's what's so
funny what kind of [__] did you watch
with them uh so my dad made me watch all
Stallone my dad was still alive so I was
my parents got divorced uh I was like
five six years old my dad would come
over his house he had a one bedroom he
would be in his tighty whities one sock
on smoking a cigarette the filter and
just like hey what's up you know and
then we would watch Rambo yeah he'd be
like this is still on like he was
[__] just badass dude just old school
just didn't give a [__] like the best
and then my mom walked in like
yeah
and like you know I just so I knew all
the Rocky movies growing up and I like
wanted to be Rocky and knew all the run
times and Carl Weathers was a athlete I
knew I just knew everything about
Stallone was so inspired by his story
because he was like uh you know his
famous story is they didn't want him to
play Rocky and he was like [__] you and
he was right and that's like I just love
that that historian did your dad tell
you that yeah yeah and he taught me that
and uh he was like that guy he's [__]
cool you know that's he he believed in
himself and then my grandpa just he's
super like autistic in like in a movie
way where he so he's actually I think
the first Bootlegger so my grandpa has
so his dad owned the uh a movie theater
in Brooklyn growing up and he was
obsessed with movies and he has I think
I don't want to get it wrong because
he'll call me he's watching he knows
everything he's so he's 84 years old so
he'd be like I read on the Instagram
that you're dating ice spice
I'm like it's a rumor he's just like all
right
so he knows everything but he I think he
has like four thousand or five thousand
VHS tapes that he personally sat on the
across the tube and recorded television
so he'll have like 8 000 tapes with five
movies on each of them has a full
Leonard Martin's guide his own reviews
so he'll be like yeah he's proud he'll
go over he's like pick an index card any
movie go ahead whatever and uh I
remember because he's old so it was like
it it goes pretty good movie pretty good
acting movie about dinosaurs Jurassic
Park that's what his like review is oh
like a pretty good movie about dinosaurs
like he's insane so I was just obsessed
with film and uh Abbott and Costello and
all slapstick and he made me watch all
that [__] and uh you know that's where
all that love so that's where that laugh
comes from just like I can't believe my
insane Grandpa who would bootleg movies
and like he would LimeWire he would he'd
call me and be like payday you heard a
LimeWire I'm like yeah what's up he's
like he's like I got the town I was like
what he goes I got the town he goes I
give it to you for like three dollars he
goes seriously he's like I give it to my
friends for five but yeah but your
grandson like myself
and I'm like I think you're gonna go to
jail so there was like he's just a movie
Nut so that's where that laugh comes
from wow yeah well did you miss along I
don't think I've ever met him I don't
I'm pretty sure I've never met him
um but
weirdly my uh
my my grandpa went to school with Harvey
Keitel and he'll tell everyone that well
listen like a waitress will be like
what's your order he'll be like I went
to school with Harvey yeah
so when I was a kid with my dad my my
pop past he called Harvey and was like
he's a big Stallone fan can you get can
you get an autograph or whatever and
Stallone wrote uh uh two Peter keep
punching Sylvester on like the great
Rocky 3 where he was just like golden
god commercial Rock like perfect uh and
yeah that was like the coolest thing I
had for a really long time yeah that's
great man [__] uh Salon just texted
me last week and he signed it no
[__] keep punching yeah no [__]
I love it dude
yeah dude and I will yeah I remember
reading that being like okay I mean well
he's probably taking a [__] just like
yeah it was just four feeder all right
whatever but to me it changed my life
[__] yeah yeah [__] it and that's what
people don't realize that how much that
means to people that's right you know
that's right yeah I uh I [__] I I did
the same thing with Stallone man I love
the [__] out of him and then we ended up
doing a movie together and it was like
cataclysmic it was just like a complete
[__] disaster with him uh you know we
we like it was like my my second son had
just been born
and uh it was a boxing movie it was like
he was fighting the Nero and I played De
Niro's song
heroic to me dude I loved it but no no
no
[__] Kevin I got a story about that
too yeah
bro bro that movie so so I'm doing I'm
doing [__] Grudge Match I had just on
Wolf of Wall Street and so Marty had
they they knew that I boxed so they were
like hey look we got this idea You're
Gonna Play De Niro's son it's like
[__] De Niro like I'll do any you
know what I mean and uh you're gonna
play Dinero's son but since you fight
we're also gonna do this flashback fight
and you're gonna play like the young
dinero and do all the boxing and I'm
like [__] yeah yeah so [__] my Justin
wolf washing so Marty gives me all these
tapes of Jake LaMotta and De Niro as a
Young Man training so I'm like I'm like
I'm like learning his technique I'm like
I'm copying his shitty [__] technique
and I'm like I'm like like learning all
the [__] and uh you know man I love De
Niro right like I [__] love De Niro
and like I love so long too you know but
uh
so when I I I I I go down where like
we're like go down for fittings or
whatever it is down in New Orleans and
my son was born super early like he he
was like almost eight weeks early like
he spent like his first two months in
the NICU and like he he wasn't getting
out of the hospital he was healthy it
was gonna work out but like he was like
three pounds it was like all [__] up
and uh
I was in New Orleans for this for the
[__] and then uh I flew home basically
like my son was getting out of the
hospital it's gonna be like the first
time I was actually going to be able to
like really get to hold him and like be
with him and when I landed in L.A from
New Orleans I get this call being like
yeah Sly wants you back in uh New
Orleans for boxing rehearsal I'm like
for what and he's like for boxing
rehearsal and I'm like the [__] is he
gonna like tell me about boxing like you
got to get back on a [__] plane you
got to go back for boxing worlds I'm
like mother like I didn't leave the
airport I'm like [__] I'm like
Okay cool so I go back and I like get my
ticket I go back to [__] New Orleans
I get there I take the button like we go
to this like Warehouse gym right and we
go to this gym and there's like posters
of Sly like all over like he he had
posters of him all over the wall like
like murals and [__] and he's in the the
ring and De Niro's in the ring with him
and like you know [__] slides in like
great [__] and like DeNiro was like you
know he's green yeah he's like yeah he's
like putting it yeah he's like putting
it effort but like I mean these guys are
like in their 70s you know I mean I walk
in I just have like my boxing bag and
like as soon as I walk in he's like yo
and I was like what's going on slide he
goes yo you're next and I was like okay
and I start like wrapping up my hands
you know whatever and I just like
[__] I start beating on this [__]
bag and they get done in the ring and
[__] slide just calls it he's like
all right everybody go home and I'm like
what the [__] did I come here for and he
goes back into the back right so I'm
just like sitting there I flew all the
way back here for no [__] reason but
his stunt doubles this guy Greg rementer
is not like a huge [__] stunt
coordinator great guy he's like hey man
you want to spar he's like we're here
like we might as well yeah let's [__]
Spar like we're here so we start going
in there we're gonna start sparring
this woman comes out of the back and she
goes into my bag right and like there's
like rules in a box like you don't touch
other people's [__] changes in life
don't touch fair enough right lady don't
touch my back she's like yeah going in
my bag we're like spying she's like
going in my bag and I'm like what are
you doing she's like you have this uh
boxing liniment in here I had this like
Thai boxing liniment which is like the
[__] you can only get in [__] Titans
super hard to get I would rub it in my
knees before I would like Spar some like
if I really needed it like numbs your
knees you can move good and she's like
Sly loves this [__] I'm gonna take in
the back I'm giving him a massage I want
to rub it on his back I'm like you just
went into my bag and she's like she's
like yeah but he loves this [__] yeah
[__]
exactly like so like I'm [__] like
already posters in here look at that
[__] lotion the lotion it's like a
little [__] jar bro yeah dude so I'm
like all right [__] take the lotion
right so I go back in like I'm sparring
[__] uh Greg and we're doing our
thing he's beating the [__] out of me
and then uh 45 minutes later Sly comes
out he's like in a [__] nice ass suit
in the top hat and he's like yo so you
got guys and he like walks by and then
the woman comes out she goes hey by the
way we're just going to go ahead and
keep that lotion because Sly really
likes it I'm like what do you mean you
got to keep you like yeah he really
likes it I'm like [__] this I sell my
mouth guard out of my headgear I like
ran out and like chasing on the street
and I was like Hey Sly man like you know
where I'm from like if you want to
borrow something from somebody you like
ask them yourself right you know what I
mean and he's like yo and I'm like nah
man you took my [__] he's like I love
you bugs in my gym and dude he's like
well [__] it I'll give it back and I'll
say no keep the [__] lit at me you
know what I mean I'm like but show me
some [__] respect man it was so bad
bro but I will say I will say that after
that like me and him did really Bond he
gave me uh I lost a different story but
he he uh you know man he's he's great
man he's great and I and I I I reached
out to him recently just because like I
see what he's doing now you talk about
working I don't know if you feel this
way too but it's kind of apropos what we
were talking about in the beginning but
like
yo man it's like there's certain people
in life like I love [__] people in
their 60s 70s and 80s who are still like
[__] trying like just but like are
just trying like are failing and like
admitting that like are still like I
really do look at at Howard Stern that
way like like who who is like gone on to
like keep evolving keep pushing like
being happier in their in their personal
life keep like looking for change look
keep trying to grow and like you know
Sly like put this interview out uh
earlier this year man where he like just
like kind of talked about his sort of
you know you know his failure with his
failings you know with some of his
family commitments and you know doing
too many of his own [__] stuff like
he's still looking at himself that way
and he's doing great [__] work and
like I don't know I just I I have a lot
of respect for that no I love that dude
man I loved as soon as I saw Tulsa King
I was like uh when I saw it I was like I
hope this is what I in my wet dreams
this would be and it was it's just him
being like this is a doobie oh my God
it wasn't like it's like it's playful
and fun and like I'm happy to see him
being [__] fun and that's that means
a lot because you see some of these
dudes getting a check super checked out
[__] banging out [__] okay and he
still gives a [__] yeah he doesn't have
that I don't think he's got that gear
man no he's like he's writing producer
he's everywhere that's right that's what
I respect that that's right and he's mad
as [__] about like the Creed stuff like
he's like he's like still like you know
what I mean he's like calling out Irwin
Winkler who's like 97. he's like
[__] stole my [__] you know
what I mean it's like true like he
created Rocky like he did that like
that's [__] huge man that's his
legacy yeah like like I think [__]
Copland is like [__] genius you know
what I mean it's like [__] it dude you
know what I mean and like that's like
probably sly's best movie you know what
I mean you know that I mean it's [__]
yeah that's a super underrated slept on
move totally anything mangle does like
that that he's a [__] he's just a
[__] gangster
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we are
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]